Oh in the dark is a new show about a
woman in her 20s who's just hot mess
hot mess a walking tornado doesn't do
anything except eat candy bars and take
nails
I think blacking out would be a little
easier when you're blind she is the
witness to the murder of a young boy
named Tyson who happens to be your best
friend and by trying to understand why
that happened she's required to pick her
life up a little bit today we're going
to answer some adulting questions yes oh
I think if she loves someone and you
feel it in your heart you should tell
it's too soon baby too soon oh oh yeah
she's
[Applause]
[Music]
personally I wouldn't text the text is
so impersonal but a nice letter from an
unknown location you can't beat it
that's the best way I know how to break
up the snail milk yes a move yeah start
a new life a new identity get new vices
oh I'm sorry your family Lucy Bootsy
Hank I think it's okay to be nervous and
to get a little sweaty I always get the
upper lips wet right here I always just
point it out yeah and then people were
like oh I get that too and then it's
like oh great
got me I think you should get my name if
I saw a dog with a cat tattoo I'd be
like whatever you asked Logan now he
feels about that he's like I don't want
a cat that do this is the best day of my
life be sure to check out in the dark on
CW I'm thirsty it before that thank you
if you're looking to adopt a dog go to
deity animal rescue and foundation
that's where you were
no just bit my beard just like a hey hey
hey what is what is the problem
[Music]